[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC - "TOTAL PRAISE"]
(SINGING) Lord, I will lift
mine eyes to the hills.
Knowing thy help.
Lord, it comes from you.
It's coming from you.
Your peace.
Your peace you give me,
Lord, in time of the storm.
You are the source
of my strength.
Everyday you are the
strength of my life.
And I lift my hand.
And I lift my hands in
total praise to you.
Lord, you are the
source of my strength.
Every day you are,
you are, yes, you
are the strength of my life.
And I lift my hands.
I lift my hands.
Yes, I do.
In total praise to you.
Amen.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - "ORDER MY STEPS"]
(SINGING) Order my steps
in your word, dear Lord.
Lead me, guide me every day.
Send your anointing,
Father, I pray.
Order my steps in your word.
Please order my
steps in your word.
Order my steps in
your word, dear Lord.
Lead me, guide me every day.
Send your anointing,
Father, I pray.
Order my steps in your word.
Please order my
steps in your word.
Humbly I ask thee
teach me and lead me.
While you are working,
help me be still.
Though Satan is
busy, God is real.
Order my steps in your word.
Please order my
steps in your word.
Bridle my tongue.
Make my words edify.
Let the words of my mouth
be acceptable in thy sight.
Take charge of my heart
both day and every night.
Order my steps in your word.
Please order my
steps in your word.
I want to walk worthy.
According to your will.
Please order my steps, Lord.
And I'll do your blessed will.
Yes, I will.
The world is ever changing.
The world is every changing,
but you are still the same.
Please order my steps, Lord.
I want to praise your name.
I want to walk worthy.
According to your will.
Please order my steps, Lord.
Please order my steps.
And I'll do your blessed will.
Yes, I will.
The world is ever changing.
But you are still the same.
Please order my steps, Lord.
And I'll praise your name.
Order my steps.
Lead me.
In your word.
Order my steps.
Teach me to speak.
In your word.
Guide my feet.
Guide my feet in your word.
In your word.
Wash my heart.
I need you to wash my
heart in your word.
Show me how to walk.
Show me how to
walk in your word.
talk in your word.
I want to learn how
to talk with you.
When I need a brand
new song to sing,
show me, show me, show me
how to let your praises ring
in your word.
In your word.
Order my steps in your word.
Please order my steps in word.
I want to walk worthy.
According to your will.
According to your blessed will.
Order my steps, Lord.
Please order my steps.
And I'll do your blessed will.
Yes, I will.
The world is ever changing.
The world is ever changing,
but you are still the same.
You are still the same.
Order my steps, Lord.
I want to praise your name.
Order my steps.
Lead me.
In your word.
Order my step.
Teach me to speak in your word.
Guide my feet in your word.
Wash my heart.
I need you to wash my
heart in your word.
Show me how to
walk in your word.
talk in your word.
I want to learn how
to talk with you.
When I need a brand
new song to sing,
show me, show me, show me
how let your praises ring
in your word.
In your word.
Please order my
steps in your word.
In your word.
Please order my
steps in your word.
In your word.
Please order my
steps in your word.
Order my steps in your word.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
(SINGING) We've got joy.
Joy in the morning start
with the rising sun.
We've got joy.
Joy in the noonday
till our work is done.
Cause we got joy.
Joy in the evening
[INAUDIBLE] night and day.
Who gives you this joy?
His name is Jesus.
Oh, we've got joy.
Joy in the morning starts
with the rising sun.
We've got joy.
Joy in the noonday
till our work is don.
Oh, we've got joy.
Joy in the evening
[INAUDIBLE] night and day.
Who gives you this joy?
His name is Jesus.
Oh, got joy within this soul.
Got joy the world can behold.
Got joy in the midst of my
problems, because I know my God
can solve them.
Then you can't stop us
from running this race.
Gotta keep on running,
running, running.
Oh, we've got joy.
Joy in the morning starts
with the rising sun.
We've got joy.
Joy in the noonday
till our work is done.
You know, we've got joy.
Joy in the evening
[INAUDIBLE] night and day.
Who gives you this joy?
His name is Jesus.
Come on.
Oh, got joy within my soul.
Got joy the world can behold.
Got joy in the midst of my
sorrow, because I know my God
can solve them.
Saying you can't stop us
from running this race.
Gotta keep on running,
running, running.
Till we see God face to face.
We've got joy.
Joy in the morning starts
with the rising sun.
Oh, we've got joy.
Joy in the noonday
till our work is done.
Oh, we've got joy.
Joy in the evening
[INAUDIBLE] night and day.
Who gives you this joy?
His name is Jesus.
You know, we've got joy.
Joy in the morning starts
with the rising sun.
You know, we've got joy.
Joy in the noonday
till our work is done.
You know, we've got joy.
Joy in the evening,
[INAUDIBLE] night and day.
Who gives you this joy?
His name is Jesus.
You know, we've got joy.
Joy in the morning
with the rising sun.
Oh, we've got joy.
Joy in the noonday
till our work is done.
You know, we've got joy.
Joy in the evening
[INAUDIBLE] night and day.
Who gives you this joy?
His name is Jesus.
You know, we've got joy.
Joy in the morning starts
with the rising son.
You know, we've got joy.
Joy in the noonday
till our work is done.
You know, we've got joy.
Joy in the evening [INAUDIBLE]
both night and day.
Who gives you this joy?
His name is Jesus.
Lily of the valley.
Bright morning star.
His name is Jesus.
In the morning.
In the noonday.
His name is Jesus.
In the evening.
Lily of the valley.
His name is Jesus.
Bright morning star.
You know, we've got joy.
Joy in the morning starts
with the rising sun.
You know, we've got joy.
Joy in the noonday
till our work is done.
Oh, we've got joy.
Joy in the evening [INAUDIBLE]
both night and day.
Who gives you this joy?
His name is Jesus.
Amen.
[APPLAUSE]
GOMEZ: Thank you.
Thank you.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Maribel
Gomez, and I am
a senior pursuing a degree
in chemical engineering.
I will be your mistress of
ceremonies during today's
breakfast celebration.
Please join me in thanking
Mr. [? Darrell ?] [? Madsen ?]
and the South Central Mass Choir
once again for their wonderful
work.
[APPLAUSE]
In the spirit of our celebration
of the life and legacy of Dr.
King, we would like to
ask you to greet or shake
hands with someone near you.
Look at the table around you,
across from you, or behind you.
Welcome, everyone, to the 20th
Annual Dr. Martin Luther King
Jr. Celebration.
I would like to take this moment
to thank President Charles
Vest and his wife, Mrs. Rebecca
Vest, for hosting this event.
I would also like to welcome
Mr. Tavis Smiley, television
correspondent, author,
and political commentator.
It is a pleasure to have
you here this morning.
Furthermore, I
would like to thank
all the members of the Martin
Luther King Jr. Planning
Committee to whom we owe
this wonderful morning.
When I call your
names, please stand up.
Professor Jerome Friedman.
[APPLAUSE]
Professor Richard Milner.
Reverend John Wuestneck.
[APPLAUSE]
Assistant Professor
Catherine Drennen.
[APPLAUSE]
Assistant Professor
Larry Anderson.
[APPLAUSE]
Associate Dean
Arnold Henderson, Jr.
[APPLAUSE]
Assistant Director
Deborah Liverman.
[APPLAUSE]
Director Ronald Critchlow.
Associate Director
Robert Sayles.
[APPLAUSE]
Co-director Paul Parravano.
Special Assistant
to the President,
Dr. Clarence G.
Williams, ex officio.
[APPLAUSE]
Chancellor L. Philip
Clay, ex officio.
And Co-chairs Dean
Leo Osgood, Jr.
[APPLAUSE]
And Professor Michael Feld.
Thank you all for contributing
to the success of this event.
Where's the Cambridge?
Do we have a choir?
We will now have the Cambridge
Rindge and Latin High School
choir led by Mr. Donald
Patterson, musical director,
lead us in singing "Lift Every
Voice and Sing" by James Weldon
Johnson.
We ask that you join in
and sing the first verse.
Please stand and join
hands as the song is sung.
[MUSIC - "LIFT EVERY VOICE AND
SING"]
(SINGING) Lift up
your voice and sing.
Till earth and heaven ring.
Ring with the
harmonies of liberty.
Let our rejoicing rise high
as the list'ning skies.
Let it resound loud
as the rolling sea.
Sing a song full of the
faith that the dark past
has taught us.
Sing a song full of the
hope that the present
has brought us.
Facing the rising sun
of the new day begun.
Let us march till
victory is won.
Stony the road we trod,
bitter the chast'ning rod,
felt in the day that
hope unborn had died.
Yet with a steady beat,
have not our weary feet,
come to the place on
which our fathers sighed?
We have come over a way that
with tears has been watered.
We have come treading our
path through the blood
of the slaughtered.
Out of the gloomy
past, till now we
stand at last where the white
gleam of our bright star
is cast.
[APPLAUSE]
GOMEZ: Thank you Mr. Donald
Patterson, musical director,
and the Cambridge Rindge
and Latin High School
choir for that outstanding
rendition of "Lift Every Voice
And Sing."
And we have one more member of
the MLK committee, Ms. Tobie
Weiner.
[APPLAUSE]
We will now begin the
program with the invocation
from Reverend John Wuestneck.
Following the invocation,
breakfast will begin.
After breakfast, we will
have two students, Georgette
Charles, class of 2003, and Eric
Caulfield, a graduate student,
guide us in reflections on the
life and legacy of Dr. King.
Dean Robert Redwine will present
the 2001-2002 Martin Luther
King Jr. Leadership Awards.
We will then have
another musical selection
from Mr. Donald Patterson and
the Cambridge Rindge and Latin
High School choir.
Then we will hear remarks
from Dr. Charles M. Vest,
and he will have the
pleasure of introducing
our keynote speaker,
Mr. Tavis Smiley.
Following the keynote speaker,
Provost Robert A. Brown
will recognize our Martin
Luther King Jr. Visiting
Professors for the 2001
and 2002 academic year.
Now let us begin our program
with the invocation by Reverend
John Wuestneck.
Right after Reverend
Wuestneck's invocation,
we will begin breakfast.
WUESTNECK: Let us pray.
Almighty God, bless
to us our gathering
on this special
occasion of celebration.
Lift us into dignity
beyond background, color,
temperament of mind, and beyond
accustomed ways of seeing.
Remind us of the privilege we
have to gather, of the gifts
we have to share all
graciously given.
Bind us together to use
our many and varied talents
for the benefit of all.
And bring us to the
dedication that we
can make a difference
in endless poverty,
in places of social disgrace,
in the violence of our world,
and in our own lives.
And help us to
find creative ways
to benefit all human beings.
Bless to us, O God, the
food which feeds our bodies.
Lift up those who
grew and raised
the food and the
people who prepared it.
Lift those also who helped with
the setting and presentation
of this feast and those who
will clean long after we
are gone from this space.
All these prayers we lift
to you, O God, and also
the silence and the yet emerging
concerns from the very centers
of our being.
Amen.
GOMEZ: Ladies and
gentlemen, I hope you
have enjoyed your breakfast.
We will now continue with
the rest of the program.
I have the pleasure
of introducing
two of our very own students
Georgette M. Charles,
a junior in biology, and Eric
Caulfield, a graduate student
in electrical engineering
and computer science.
They will guide us in a
reflection of the life
and legacy of Dr. King.
We will hear first from
Georgette M. Charles.
CHARLES: Distinguished
faculty, guests, students,
administrators, and our gracious
hosts, President and Mrs. Vest,
I come before you as a
humble servant of God
to reflect on the life and
legacy of Dr. Martin Luther
King.
When I was asked to give this
speech, the first question
that I had in my
mind was, what do I
want people to open their
eyes, minds, and hearts to?
In starting with
this reflection,
I went back to the principles
of Dr. King, who always believed
in knowing where
you are coming from
and where you are before even
mentioning where you are going,
so that is what I will do.
To tell you where
I'm coming from,
I will start by saying, I am
an undergraduate here at MIT,
a junior majoring
in biology, minoring
in environmental
health and toxicology.
Additionally, I'm the
current Vice Chairperson
of the MIT Chapter
of the National
Society of Black Engineers.
But today, I stand before
you as a representative
of neither standing.
They are mere
undercurrents of who I am
and who I consider myself to be.
Today, before you, I
represent a leader,
and no one has to
verify that fact.
I know that I am a leader
because I know when to start
my day and when to end it.
I don't think that I can
compare myself to Dr. King,
but I will remark,
he is a leader also--
not was, but is.
In the words of
Coretta Scott King,
"He remains a shining example
of a discerning leader,
one who shows good
judgment and insight."
There are many leaders
around me, but how many
are as astute as Dr. King?
Sure, some can gather
followers, but how tactful are
the causes for which they lead?
And what cause should
they be leading?
The question that I
pose before you today
is, to what or for
what should we lead?
To answer this question,
I started digging back,
back to the life of Dr.
King, for these answers.
I'm not quite sure if he
gave me a clear cut solution,
but he started opening up my
mind to some possible ones.
Allow me to share.
Let us talk about
purpose and cause.
Many leaders are born with
the rightful talent to lead.
They may have great oratorical
skills, a beautiful, loud
voice, are persuasive
in speech, but does that
make them a good leader?
No.
What makes them a
good leader is if they
choose a valid and
purposeful path
for those that
follow them, if they
choose not to lead them astray.
The first quality
of a good leader
is one who will never take
his eyes off the prize,
to make life better for others.
Another important quality is
to be an exceptional learner,
to open one's eyes, mind,
and heart to the truth.
Do not be blindsided by
what is easy and fruitless.
But beyond being an
exceptional learner and leader,
Dr. King was a teacher.
He made leaders.
He took his God-given talent
and stood at the pulpit
and said, people, are you
tired of bus segregation?
Will you walk?
Well, they were so
tired of that bus
that thousands of citizens
of Montgomery, Alabama,
both black and white,
walked every day
for more than six months.
But the truth remains
that they became leaders
when they followed Dr. King.
They took their
energy and strength,
and got up, and started walking
with their two feet, and said,
we won't sit in
the back anymore.
If I was to tell you to remember
anything today, I would say,
do not be that leader
that lets people
sit in the back of the bus.
They deserve the front,
back, left side, right,
whatever they desire.
This is the problem I see
that we need to resolve.
It is the problem
with leadership
that doesn't have the motivation
to build more leaders, to build
and sustain inclusion.
What do I mean by inclusion?
It is allowing equal
opportunity for everyone
to achieve success.
Many view the illusion
of full inclusion
is that glass ceiling that
no one can seem to break.
Well, I apologize
if I offend you.
Upon my reflection
of Dr. King's life,
I think it is quite
naive to believe
that one can break the glass
ceiling by his or herself.
Don't try to climb
to the top alone.
If you do, you will bump your
head and fall right back down.
We-- and I mean we--
need to work first
at teaching so
that when we are
psychologically prepared
to climb to the
highest peak together,
we will break
through any barriers.
Remember, Dr. King taught that
inequality cannot be taken over
by force alone.
We must first teach
the notion of equality.
Then and only then,
can we begin to talk
about injustice and inequality.
Then and only then, will the
illusion of total inclusion
transform into a clear
and tangible objective.
Thank you, and good morning.
[APPLAUSE]
GOMEZ: Thank you, Georgette.
We will now hear
from Eric Caulfield.
CAULFIELD: Good morning.
AUDIENCE: Good morning.
CAULFIELD: My name is
Russell Eric Caulfield,
and I'm a graduate
student in the Department
of Electrical Engineering
and Computer Science
and a proud graduate of
Morehouse College of which
Dr.--
[APPLAUSE]
--of Which Dr. King
was an alumnus.
When I first got
the email saying
that I would get to speak at
the Martin Luther King Jr.
Breakfast, I was thrilled,
delighted, excited, elated,
and amused, ecstatic, overjoyed,
and completely enthused--
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
--at the opportunity
to stand in front
of such an awesome and
diversely beautiful
gathering of human beings.
And now, as I stand
here, it does my heart
good to gaze out upon such a
celestial cornucopia of colors.
[LAUGHTER]
A sublime symphony of hues, a
magnificently marvelous mosaic
of men and women of
different backgrounds, races,
and religions.
For in looking at
this group, one
could be led to believe that
the quest of the man whom
we commemorate on this morning
had indeed been completed.
However, if one
were to take time
to ponder the preponderance
of perplexing peculiarities
persistently plaguing
people, then one
might come to the
conclusion that what
we are, in fact,
seeing is indeed
an illusion, more specifically,
the illusion of full inclusion.
If visitors from
another world were
to drop by this
breakfast and peek in,
then they might think
that we here at MIT
are indeed the
fulfillment of the dream.
But were they to visit the
lecture halls and office
buildings on a normal Friday
morning, what they would find
is that there are less
than 150 African Americans
in a graduate school of
nearly 6,000 students
and that there are less than 130
Hispanics in that same graduate
school.
More shockingly,
what they would find
is that of the 486 full
tenured professors here at MIT,
only seven of them
are African American.
And of the 486 full tenured
professors here at MIT,
only six of them are Hispanic.
Granted, great
strides have been made
in terms of gender inclusion
at the undergraduate level,
though women make up less than
30% of the graduate school
and less than 20%
of the faculty.
What we have to
recognize is that issues
of gender and racial inclusion
are not mutually exclusive
but, instead, are complementary.
For it's only when
we have men and women
of different backgrounds
working together can
we hope to achieve a full
range of new, insightful, and
innovative perspectives.
[APPLAUSE]
But unfortunately, many of us
who grew up in a microwave,
TV dinner, give-it-to-me-now,
I-want-it-yesterday type
of society, expect that
inclusion will ride in like
a handsome knight on a horse and
we sit back saying, inclusion,
inclusion, wherefore
art thou, inclusion?
[LAUGHTER]
But we have to
recognize that we are
wrestling against the
momentum of history,
constantly spiraling downward,
plowing a path where,
if unchecked, the
greedy, and ruthless,
and short-sighted
tyrants of the world
might actually have their way.
Ultimately, what we
have to recognize
is that the B boy from Brooklyn,
the chemist from Cambodia,
the EE from Indonesia,
the MD from Mexico,
the botanist from Botswana,
the mathematician from Morocco,
the ecologist from England,
the geologist from Germany,
the poli sci from Poland,
and the psychiatrist
from Sri Lanka, the
architect from Argentina
all bring to the table something
different and yet the same--
competence and diversity.
They say that great
minds think alike,
but I submit that truly
exceptional minds think
differently, for it is
our charge as sojourners
in this magnificent academic
mega mecca to think differently
and to grapple earnestly
with full inclusion.
Chasing truth never has been
and never will be an easy task,
but we can keep in mind the
words of Arthur William Edgar
O'Shaughnessy who wrote,
"We are the music makers.
And we are the
dreamers of dreams
wandering by the
lone sea breakers
and sitting by desolate streams.
The world-losers and the
world-forsakers on whom
the pale moon gleams.
Yet we are the movers and
shakers of the world forever
it seems."
In remembering Dr. King, we
should remember his work.
We must embrace difference,
press for equality,
and break the rose-colored
glasses of sameness
that prevent us from
seeing through the illusion
of full inclusion.
So on this day of
remembrance, let
us not only commemorate
the man, but let
us also remember his mission.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
GOMEZ: Thank you, Eric.
That was a wonderful speech.
Once again, I'd like to
thank both Eric Caulfield
and Georgette Charles for
those wonderful remarks
and for letting the words--
[APPLAUSE]
--and for letting the words of
Dr. King be heard once more.
I hope that everyone
here today has really
had a chance to listen
carefully to their words.
Now I have the honor of
introducing Dean Robert P.
Redwine, who will present the
2001 MLK Leadership Awards.
[APPLAUSE]
REDWINE: Good morning.
AUDIENCE: Good morning.
REDWINE: I really don't
know why I always have
to follow speeches like that.
[LAUGHTER]
But it is indeed an
honor and a privilege
to be able to present this
year's Dr. Martin Luther King
Jr. Leadership Awards
to four remarkable
and deserving individuals.
As some of you know,
this happy task
would normally have
been carried out
by our Chancellor,
Professor Philip Clay.
Phil is not able to
be with us today,
and I think I may
understand why now
after he realized Eric would be
preceding him on the program.
[LAUGHTER]
But I am certainly pleased to
be able to serve in his absence.
I will ask each
of the recipients
to come forward one at a time
to receive his or her award.
After I offer some words
of congratulations,
each recipient will then
have the opportunity
to make a few remarks as well.
I'd like first to ask Dr. Randal
Pinkett to come forward please.
[APPLAUSE]
Dr. Pinkett is an
alumnus of MIT,
having received the MBA, SM, and
PhD degrees from the Institute.
He is also a graduate of
Rutgers University and a Rhodes
Scholar.
He is currently chief
executive officer
of Building Community with
Technology, a consulting
firm in Plainfield, New Jersey.
Randal, those who nominated
you for this award
cited your an
extraordinary ability
to inspire, encourage,
and lead others
as well the exceptional
ways that you
have made significant
and lasting contributions
to the advancement of low income
people in urban neighborhoods.
While completing your
doctorate in the Media Lab, you
and graduate colleague,
Richard O'Bryant
created a highly effective model
for bridging the digital divide
by implementing a
computer network
in Camfield Estates of Roxbury.
This innovative
undertaking quickly
enhanced the neighborhood's
capacity for community
building and accessing
vital technology
and has drawn
national recognition.
Your considerable
accomplishments
as a Rhodes Scholar, engineer,
community leader, researcher,
and entrepreneur
embodies so much
of what Dr. King desired
for all in our society.
Your willingness to share
these talents with others
is not only admirable
but an exemplary way
of continuing his dream.
It gives me great pleasure to
present to you this year's Dr.
Martin Luther King
Jr. Leadership Award.
[APPLAUSE]
PINKETT: I want thank you for
the wonderful presentation
of the award and also
giving honor to God
who is at the head of my life.
I also--
[APPLAUSE]
Yes.
It's actually here in Boston
that I reclaimed my faith
at Morningstar Baptist Church
after two years abroad.
Coming back to the
Lord and coming back
to the family of God has
been truly a blessing for me.
And I continue to reap
the benefits of having
rejoined the Body of Christ.
I want to first
give a shout out,
so to speak, to
Georgette and to Eric
for the wonderful
remarks they gave
on the reflections of Dr. King.
[APPLAUSE]
I was, I was, I'm
so proud and floored
at both of your remarks.
I want to just briefly
reflect on our theme
this morning, which is
from dreams to reality.
Many look at the way we talk
about Dr. King as a dreamer
and argue or sometimes
want to suggest that
by framing him in that
way that Dr. King may
have had his head in the
clouds or was unrealistic
in his expectations.
Or you kind of begin to
fantasize that he didn't really
have a handle on the issues
because we constantly make
reference to the
man-- he had a dream--
and the dream.
But I believe when
you really cut
to the core of what that
means, that to really effect
change in society,
to really find
ways to transform our day-to-day
reality, you have to be,
in some respects, a dreamer.
You have to believe
that in some way
you are able to affect or
create a new reality that you
don't see physically or within
your everyday experience.
I've heard people say
faith is an acronym that
stands Feeling As
If Things Happened,
actually believing
that something
has come to manifest itself.
And when we look at
children, for example,
and the childlike qualities
that young people have where
they almost suspend reality and
believe that they can do almost
anything, I believe Dr.
King retained something
about that quality, that
he believed somewhere
within himself that
he could do anything,
that he could see a
world that we see today
or that we're working
toward seeing today,
as Eric mentioned.
That was a new
manifestation of inclusion.
And I think about
the environment
that he must have worked within.
There had to have been people
around him that said, Martin,
you're crazy.
Martin, to think
that you're going
to be able to make
the kind of changes
that you want to
be able to make,
you're not going to
be able to do it.
But somehow, in some way, he
was able to move beyond that,
to move beyond that and hold
onto that childlike quality,
again, that helps us to
believe we can do anything.
And so I stand at
this podium today
realizing that I never
would have imagined
that I would have received a
Rhodes Scholarship or three
degrees from MIT or
a Martin Luther King
Award for Leadership at MIT.
And I'm honored,
and I'm blessed,
and I'm humbled that MIT
has chosen to recognize me
for what I've done so far.
And I hope that I'm
able to continue
to do good work moving forward.
And I just want to
end by recognizing
some of those that are here
this morning that have come out
to share in this honor.
First, my mom,
Elizabeth Pinkett,
who came here up from
New Jersey along with me.
Mom.
I want to thank her.
My father is deceased.
And I want to thank
my mom for being
the strength and the
guiding force in my life
and for really instilling
the values in me
and continuing to be a
support there for me.
And I love you, Mom.
And I appreciate you for that.
I want to also recognize my
advisor, Mitchel Resnick, who's
here somewhere--
Mitchel, just raise your hand--
who's been very supportive in
my doctoral work here at MIT.
[APPLAUSE]
And just a few others.
Ceasar McDowell, who's here, a
member of my thesis committee,
Richard O'Bryant, who was
mentioned in my bio, who
helped me out with the
product over in Roxbury,
the family of people of color
here at MIT, Chris Jones
and Robin and Deans
Osgood and Colbert,
and Melissa McDaniels,
Dean Charles, Dean Staton,
Brian [INAUDIBLE], all those.
And last but not
least, I want to thank
the residents of Camfield, where
I've worked for the past three
years.
I'm working with them to
look at ways technology can
improve low income communities.
Nakia Keizer, Paulette Ford,
Thaddeus Miles, Wayne Williams,
Donna Fisher, Garfield,
Luis, and the whole board.
Thank you very much.
God bless all of you.
[APPLAUSE]
REDWINE: Thank you, Randal.
Next, I would like to
ask Sergeant Cheryl
Vossmer to come forward please.
[APPLAUSE]
Sergeant Vossmer has been an
MIT police officer for 17 years.
She has been a longtime member
of the President's Committee
on Campus Race Relations and
has demonstrated in many ways
a commitment to better
communication and understanding
between MIT's
various communities.
Cheryl, those who
nominated you cited
your longstanding commitment to
maintaining the values of Dr.
King by enthusiastically
serving the students, staff,
and faculty of MIT and many
residents of greater Cambridge.
You consider the
successful attainment
of a good and livable community
as part of your job and work
hard to keep this ideal in
the forefront of your mind.
Whether you are assisting
a troubled student,
participating in World
AIDS Day activities,
considering an issue before
the Campus Committee on Race
Relations, or collecting toys
for disadvantaged children,
you are known as a thoughtful
and compassionate professional
who takes her responsibilities
very seriously.
Your philosophy
and actions embody
Dr. King's forever
challenging question,
what are you doing for others?
It gives me great pleasure to
present to you this year's Dr.
Martin Luther King
Jr. Leadership Award.
[APPLAUSE]
VOSSMER: Thank you.
I'm a little bit
shorter, so I have
to roll with this a little bit.
But I just want to
say thank you so very
much for this prestigious honor.
It's difficult for me to be
recognized for doing the things
that I love to do.
I'm very humbled, and thank you.
As you all know, I also have
a difficult time standing
behind a podium.
I'd much rather be out walking
around with all of you.
But the Reverend Zina Jacque--
she's from Boston--
she told a story which
had a wonderful effect on me.
And I want to share
just a bit with you.
Many of you will be
very familiar with it.
It was about a small,
young boy named David
and how he took one smooth rock
to slay a giant named Goliath.
David went on to become
a king, a leader.
Some of you may have
picked up the rocks
that you found on
your table today.
Carry it with you.
Let it be a reminder
that you can take on
more than you think
that you can handle.
Because it only takes one
smooth rock to slay a giant.
A few weeks ago, I
had the privilege
to travel to Ground
Zero in New York City
and volunteer with
others from MIT.
And I'd like to
read a letter to you
from a sixth grader from
the Roger Park Middle School
in Danbury, Connecticut.
She writes, "Dear World
Trade Center rescue workers,
I feel you're doing a good job.
I thank you for spending
your time to help.
I also want to thank you
for sacrificing your health.
You have made a
difference in America.
God bless America.
Your friend, Kirsten."
I share this letter with you
because, as this young lady
points out, you have made a
difference to all of America.
You, too, can make a
difference in the world.
And as Dr. Martin
Luther, Jr., said,
"Life's most persistent
and urgent question
is, what are you
doing for others?"
In our workaday lives, we are
filled with the opportunities
to bless others.
The power of a single glance
or an encouraging smile
must never be underestimated.
As Dr. Martin Luther
King, again, he said,
our most urgent question is,
what are you doing for others.
So in closing, let
me say, whatever
your ideas, whatever your
goals or commitments are,
your leadership must
come from your heart.
My heart I give to you.
I know how grateful I am.
My attitude's of gratitude.
And I'm grateful
that so many people
care to make a
difference to overcome
the evil acts of a few.
Believe in yourself,
and ask yourself,
what are you doing for others?
Thank you very much.
You've all made a
difference in my life.
[APPLAUSE]
REDWINE: Thank you, Cheryl.
Next, I ask Professor Paul
Gray to come forward please.
[APPLAUSE]
Professor Gray is, of course,
very well-known to the MIT
community, having served in
a number of important roles,
including as president of the
Institute from 1980 to 1990.
He, in fact, was one of those
who started in MIT's annual MLK
celebration in 1977.
He is currently an
active faculty member
in the Department of Electrical
Engineering and Computer
Science.
Paul, those who nominated
you for this award
cited your steadfast
and enduring commitment
as a faculty member and
senior administrator
to providing equal opportunities
and higher education
for people of color.
As chair of the Task Force on
Educational Opportunity first
convened in September 1968, you
took on an unprecedented role,
developing institutional
policies that
led to the admission of 42
African American students
by the next academic year.
Those who witnessed that
era can now more fully
appreciate how daunting it
was for all men and women
to lead equitably
and responsibly
during a time of great change.
However, because of a
far-reaching vision and ability
to stand firmly by
your principles,
you frequently and
effectively have advocated
for greater inclusion.
Through your sponsorship of
the first national conference
on issues facing
black administrators
at predominantly white
colleges and universities held
on this campus in 1982 and your
appointment of Dean Shirley
McBay to the
Academic Council, you
have demonstrated an
unrelenting desire
to foster a clearer
understanding and awareness
of racial issues
in our community.
As a compassionate
advisor and mentor,
you have tirelessly guided
students and professionals
to greater levels
of achievement.
Your more than 40 years of
service on behalf of others
embodies the values
and ideals of Dr. King.
Your efforts have
helped many who still
want to sustain his dream.
It gives me great pleasure to
present to you this year's Dr.
Martin Luther King
Jr. Leadership Award.
[APPLAUSE]
GRAY: Thank you.
And my heartfelt thanks
to the planning committee,
to all who were involved in
making this day possible.
I came to MIT in the watershed
year of the 20th century, 1950.
And with a little time
out for military service,
I've been involved now at MIT
in a variety of capacities
for just 50 years.
It is clear to me that
MIT, at the opening
of the 21st century, is a far
richer, warmer, more humane
place than it was 50 years ago.
And it is so because of the
presence in significant numbers
of people of color,
of Hispanic people,
of women, of Native Americans.
MIT has changed.
People in this room are
a part of that change.
And it has made a
genuine difference.
Now Eric Caulfield is right.
There is much that
remains to be done.
We have taken first steps
on that road from the dream
to reality.
And there remain
many steps still
to be taken to achieve
the outcome of which he
spoke so eloquently.
I felt privileged
and grateful to have
had the opportunity
in the late 1960s
to work with people such
as Shirley Jackson, Jim
Turner, John Mims,
Al Hill, to take
those first steps toward making
MIT a more inclusive place.
In the years since then,
I've had the opportunity
to work with many others--
my friend Clarence Williams,
Jerry Friedman, Leo Osgood,
Mike Colbert, and many others.
It is the effort--
the steady, persistent effort--
of individuals who are
committed to moving along
the path from that dream to
a new reality that have made
and will continue to make at
MIT a difference in the nature
of this community,
will continue to push
this institution, this very
special place, along the road
to full participation in the
entire community of this nation
and of this world as it
will be in the 21st century.
Thank you all very much.
[APPLAUSE]
REDWINE: Thank you, Paul.
Next, I ask Ms. Tamara Williams
to come forward please.
[APPLAUSE]
Ms. Williams is a
graduate student
in the Department of Electrical
Engineering and Computer
Science.
She is a 1998 graduate of
Tennessee State University.
At MIT, she has been a
leader and several on-campus
organizations.
She has also volunteered
for Tutoring Plus
and has worked with Cambridge
public school students
in mathematics and English.
Tamara, those who nominated
you for this award
cited your range of
enriching contributions
to the MIT community.
While undertaking doctoral
studies at the Artificial
Intelligence Laboratory
you have committed
to serving as Co-chair of
the Black Graduate Student
Association and of
Color Creations.
Your creative leadership
of these organizations
has motivated and enabled
other graduate students
to attend the National Society
of Black Engineers National
Convention where they
shared information
about their disciplines and
encouraged potential applicants
to consider further studies
in science and technology.
You have also reached out to
fellow student organizations
by coordinating monthly dinners
and developing networking
opportunities for individuals
and groups concerned
with issues that
affect women of color.
As a volunteer in
Tutoring Plus, you
assisted Cambridge's
elementary, middle school,
and high school students with
their mathematics and language
arts subjects.
You have distinguished
yourself as a contributor
to the quality of
life on this campus,
and your efforts
honorably represent
what Dr. King expected
of himself and of others.
Your recognition is a fitting
tribute to his memory.
It is with great
pleasure that I present
to you this year's Dr. Martin
Luther King Jr. Leadership
Award.
[APPLAUSE]
WILLIAMS: Good
morning, everyone.
AUDIENCE: Good morning.
WILLIAMS: First, I'd like to
thank Marilyn Pierce and Peggy
Carney of the Electrical
Engineering Department
for nominating me
for this award.
I'd also like to thank
the leadership committee
for deeming me worthy to receive
such a great honor because I
am indeed humbled,
and I feel great.
I'd like to pose a
question to you all.
That question is, how do
you measure your success?
Do you measure it by how
many degrees you have?
How much money you make?
How many cars you have?
What type of house you live in?
Well, some time ago in my
lifetime, I read a quote--
and I can't remember who
actually said this statement.
However, it has really helped
me with my outlook on life.
And the quote is,
"measure your success
based on how many people
you make successful."
Can you imagine if the faculty,
the staff, the students,
the citizens, you
citizens here today,
if you had that outlook
on life and when
thinking about yourself,
you actually took
a step back and said,
is a little time
out of my day contributing?
Saying hi to someone,
giving someone a warm smile,
or even helping someone
with their schoolwork,
or talking to someone
about their problems--
how beneficial is that
going to be to that person?
But most importantly,
even to yourself,
it's very rewarding
to give to others.
Because in the end, you're
really helping yourself.
And I just want everyone here
to just leave with that thought.
Measure your success
based on how many people
you makes successful.
And I guarantee the world
will be a very better place--
a better place.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
REDWINE: Thank you, Tamara.
And I'd just like to
congratulate all four winners
again.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
GOMEZ: Thank you very much.
And again, congratulations
to the recipients
of all the awards.
I'd like to take a
moment to give you
a little announcement about
the MLK seminar installation.
And I'll read a little
bit of this brochure that
was available at the front.
"Since January 1999, students
in the Martin Luther King Junior
IAP Design Seminar have created
installations in Lobby 10
to depict the struggles and
accomplishments of African
Americans and other people
of color throughout history.
This year's centerpiece
demonstrates
the theme of the MLK
breakfast speaker,
From Dreams to Reality--
The Illusion of Full Inclusion.
From afar, you see a
circle of mannequins.
As you are invited
to join in the circle
by standing in the
middle, you realize
that none of the mannequins
are looking toward you.
Instead, they have
their backs to you,
and you are standing
on the word minority."
Just a little preview,
and I invite all of you
to go to Lobby 10 and take
a look at the installation.
And now, we have
another selection
by the Cambridge Rindge
and Latin High School choir
led by Mr. Donald Patterson.
[MUSIC - "I HAVE A DREAM"]
(SINGING) I have a dream today.
I have a dream.
I have a dream today.
From every mountainside,
let freedom ring.
I have a dream today.
We shall overcome.
From every mountainside,
let freedom ring.
I have a dream today.
We shall overcome.
Every valley shall be exalted.
Every hill and mountain low.
The rough places
will be made plain
and the crooked places straight.
Every valley shall be exalted.
Every hill and mountain low.
The rough places will be
made plain and crooked places
straight.
And the glory of the Lord,
and the glory of the Lord,
and the glory of the
Lord shall be revealed.
And the glory of the Lord,
and the glory of the Lord,
and the glory of the
Lord shall be revealed.
I have a dream today.
I have a dream.
From every mountainside,
let freedom ring.
I have a dream today
we shall overcome.
From every mountainside,
let freedom ring.
I have a dream today
we shall overcome.
Every valley shall be exalted.
Every hill and mountain low.
The rough places
will be made plain,
and the crooked places straight.
Every valley shall be exalted.
Ever hill and mountain low.
The rough places
will be made plain,
and the crooked place straight.
And the glory of the Lord,
and the glory of the Lord,
and the glory of the
Lord shall be revealed.
And the glory of the Lord,
and the glory of the Lord,
and the glory of the
Lord shall be revealed.
And all flesh, and all
flesh, and all flesh
shall see it together.
And all flesh, and all
flesh, and all flesh
shall see it together.
And all flesh, and all
flesh, and all flesh
shall see it together.
And all flesh, and all
flesh, and all flesh
shall see it together.
And all flesh, and all
flesh, and all flesh
shall see it together.
And all flesh, and all
flesh, and all flesh
shall see it together.
And all flesh, and all
flesh, and all flesh
shall see it together.
And all flesh, and all
flesh, and all flesh
shall see it together.
And all flesh, and all
flesh, and all flesh
shall see it together.
And all flesh, and all
flesh, and all flesh
shall see it together.
I have a dream today.
I have a dream.
And all flesh, and all
flesh, and all flesh
shall see it together.
And all flesh, and all
flesh, and all flesh
shall see it together.
I have a dream today.
I have a dream.
[APPLAUSE]
GOMEZ: Thank you again to the
Cambridge Rindge and Latin High
School choir.
Now President Vest
will give some remarks
and proceed to introduce our
keynote speaker, Mr. Tavis
Smiley.
[APPLAUSE]
VEST: Thank you, Mirabel.
And good morning, everybody.
AUDIENCE: Good morning.
VEST: Thank you
all for coming out
this morning to take part
in this great annual MIT
tradition.
It's always a real highlight
of Becky's and my year.
But Eric, I have
to tell you, when
I got the email asking me
to come here this morning, I
knew, yet again, I would be
absolutely humbled by people
like Georgette and Eric,
by their rhetorical skills,
of course, but also by the
clarity of their thought,
the steadfastness
of their heart,
their focus on the cause.
I'm especially pleased that
we are joined this morning
by many friends and colleagues
from the wider Cambridge
community, our community.
We are all citizens of this
great city on the banks
of the Charles River.
Cambridge is our common ground.
We work hard to make it a
vital and sustaining community
for all.
And it is fitting
that we come together
to celebrate this morning.
And so I would like to extend
special welcomes to City
Councilor Denise Simmons.
[APPLAUSE]
State Representative
Paul DeMarcus
was with us through most of
the morning but had to leave,
so we thank him in absentia.
Chairman Benjamin Barnes
from the Cambridge Licensing
Commission.
[APPLAUSE]
Melvina Monteiro,
Executive Director
of the Cambridge Police
Review Advisory Board.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you all very, very much
for joining us this morning.
One year ago at
this gathering, I
noted that 2001
was an iconic date,
the year, as everybody
at MIT knows,
of Arthur C. Clarke's
Space Odyssey.
Arthur C. Clarke
and Stanley Kubrick
imagined that 2001
would be remembered
as a year in which computers
became nearly human
and in which everyday
passengers would
board spacecraft
and drift gracefully
toward a colony on the moon.
In reality, this past
year will be remembered
as the time when everyday
passengers boarded aircraft
not five miles from
where we sit this morning
and pierced our
proudest buildings,
ending the lives of more than
3,000 innocent people going
about their daily business.
We discovered some
elemental truths--
that evil is bred by ignorance,
and poverty, and absolutism,
that our own technology
can be turned
against us by the crudest
actions of determined people.
At the same time, the memory
of that terrible reality
will always conjure in
our minds the sounds
of people of every color,
creed, and corner of our country
singing America the
Beautiful together.
It has been a dark time,
and it has cried out
for new understandings.
A month after the attacks,
The New York Times
ran a story whose headline was
"Attack Narrows Racial Divide."
Listen to an excerpt
from that story.
"Ever so slightly, the
attacks on the Trade Center
have tweaked the city's
traditional racial divides.
Some of it is how
ordinary men and women
react to each other on
the streets, on subways,
and bodegas.
Some people attribute
it to the solemnity
that hangs over the
city, others to fear.
Still others to a new
found unity as Americans.
Whatever it is, the way that
New Yorkers perceive one another
across color lines, however
accurate those perceptions were
to begin with, has changed."
And in December, the
Tampa, Florida Tribune
reported on interviews
with two dozen people
about race relations,
noting that,
"maybe it's a
veneer, as some say.
Maybe there's something deeper.
But after the attacks,
some black Americans
noticed that whites
talked to them more.
Others felt less vulnerable
to racial profiling.
Knowing that suspicion
had found a new target,
they struggled with
their emotions."
It is undeniable that crisis
and fear drew all Americans
together as never before.
In the face of adversity,
we build bridges.
My question this morning is,
why can we not bridge divides
in the face of opportunity?
First, historians point out that
this phenomenon of sudden unity
and bridge building is
observed frequently in wartime
but that it should not
be expected to last long.
And indeed, just a couple of
weeks after the New York Times
article, The Boston
Globe reported
that many said the
shared tragedy had quote,
"briefly bridged
Boston's racial divide."
Briefly.
And listen again to the
statement from the Tampa
Tribune, that African
Americans they interviewed
felt some relief over improved
relationships with whites
but struggled with their
emotions knowing that,
"suspicion had
found a new target."
Therein lies a
huge warning sign.
Our nation, indeed, is
at war with terrorism.
And we must take unusual
care to ensure the safety
and security of our land
and of all the people
who dwell within it.
But we also must
remain an open society.
And we surely must
maintain open universities.
Without openness, there
can be no inclusion.
And openness means openness not
only across American society,
but also openness to serious and
talented students and scholars
who come to our shores
from other countries
to build a new America.
MIT is very proud of
our Nobel Prize winners.
Those laureates who currently
are active in our midst
were born in the United
States, Italy, Germany, Mexico,
Japan, and India.
No more than that
need be said to show
why we must guard the grand
tradition of welcoming those
who come here from every
corner of the world
to learn and to advance our
institutions and our country.
But even as we
pursue the principle
of international openness,
we know full well
that race remains a deeply
troubling issue in America.
We must be unwavering
in our quest
to eradicate this
reality from our society.
We must accelerate the
movement of inclusion
from illusion to reality.
So here are two
particular challenges
for all of us today--
not only to fight for
gains in mutual respect
and understanding,
but to sustain them,
to make sure that they are not
brief, sentimental aberrations
but permanent improvements
of heart and habit,
and to understand
that if all we achieve
is to broaden the
definition of "us"
while still indulging
our desires to believe
in some broad, sinister
"them," we have not really
grown any closer to
what Dr. King called
the beloved community.
Now "community" is a
word worth pausing over.
None of us may be prepared
to define it precisely.
But I believe that within
the larger family of MIT,
community is a concept that
people understand, think
about, and value these days in
a way we may not have before.
And I believe that
was increasingly true
even before September 11, 2001.
Several years ago,
our Task Force
on Student Life
and Learning put us
on a new path of
building community
into the educational
experience of our students.
And we have seen it begin to
take hold among our students,
the design of our new
buildings, and new programs
inside and outside
our classrooms.
These commitments
and new opportunities
should mean a true
living together,
a true working
together, regardless
of race, class, culture, age,
field of study, religion,
or experience.
I wish, as Eric pointed out,
that I could say that that were
uniformly the case at MIT,
but of course, I can't.
Not yet.
We've made progress
over the years,
but we need to
rededicate ourselves
to the principles of
openness and inclusion
if we are to have
a real community.
The fact remains that most
American adults live largely
segregated lives.
Our workplaces are
increasingly mixed,
but our neighborhoods
typically are not.
For white students especially,
their years here at MIT
may, in fact, be the most
integrated experience
of their entire life.
And yet, we have much
to do if our students--
all of our students--
are to have the real benefits
of living and studying
in a truly multicultural
and multiracial community.
This begins with
admissions and access.
If we are to provide the kind
of environment and education
that our students
deserve, we must reach out
and be open to all those
who will best contribute
to and benefit from MIT.
Without access, there
is no inclusion.
We will-- and let there be no
misunderstanding about this--
we will continue our commitment
to affirmative action
in admissions.
We will continue to follow the
tenets of the Bakke decision,
and we will continue to do the
hard work necessary to recruit
to MIT extraordinarily talented
African Americans, Latinos,
Native Americans, and
other students of color.
But admitting a richly
diverse class each year,
as has been said today,
is just the beginning.
We have an opportunity and,
I believe, an obligation
to make the MIT experience
as positive, constructive,
and transformative
as possible for each
and every one of our students
individually and collectively.
We truly must get
beyond the illusion
and on to the reality
of full inclusion.
It will take time, and goodwill,
and hard work, and faith.
But I know that it can be
done, that we will reach
the place where we
can meet each other
and know each other
simply as human beings,
not as distant
representatives of some group.
And when we do, we will have
found the most important route
to mutual understanding
and true equality.
Despite our
frustrations, I continue
to be an optimist,
perhaps because I
see so many bright
signs close by here
in our own community starting
with our four award winners
this morning.
And another undeniably bright
sign has been here with us,
too, in the person
of Tavis Smiley.
As you probably know,
Tavis has launched
a new daily audio magazine
on National Public
Radio geared to an
African American audience.
But that was only after
he had established himself
as a wildly popular institution
in a dozen other ways
with a long running
program on BET,
as a frequent commentator
on several different radio
and television networks, as
the author of five books,
including How To Make
Black America Better.
But I must say that my
favorite fact about Tavis
is that he is currently
running symposiums
across the country designed to
promote the use of technology
within the African
American community.
As he puts it, the
subject is e-inclusion,
making a digital difference.
E-inclusion, openness, and
opportunity across our nation
and around the world are things
that are very much on minds
here at MIT as we
work to make together
to make virtually all of
our educational materials
freely available to
everyone in the world
through our
OpenCourseWare project.
But enough about us.
Ladies and gentlemen,
it's my great pleasure
to introduce Mr. Tavis Smiley.
[APPLAUSE]
SMILEY: Thank you.
Y'all better sit down, I
ain't said nothing yet.
You might want that back
in about 20 minutes.
I always laugh at folk who give
standing ovations before you've
ever said anything.
You may disagree with
everything I had to say.
Why did I stand
up for that Negro
before he ever said something?
I'm delighted to be in
Cambridge and to be back
in the great state
of Massachusetts.
Let me commence by thanking
your president, Mr. Vest,
and his wife for
their fine hospitality
and for being our
tablemates this morning.
We had good conversation,
delighted to sit with them.
I'm also honored to
be at the same table
with your immediate
past president, Dr.
Gray, and his wife.
And so it's a good feeling
to go somewhere and have
two presidents show up
to greet you at a table.
I must have done
something right, I guess,
or been lucky for the
right table to sit at.
So thank you for being here.
I think it is very important.
It's always important
for me at least,
and it makes an impression on
me when you show up somewhere
at a celebration such
as this and the folk
who are in charge, who happen
not to be African American,
deem it important and necessary
to be there themselves.
And so I'm always
honored to see persons
who are in charge of
making decisions who
value these issues, as
evidenced by their presence
and indeed by their
strong words this morning
understand that the real
essence of diversity
is something that
has to be addressed
and that diversity and
tolerance of not just words
but indeed ways of
life that we have
to be more serious about making
our reality on a daily basis.
Let me also, before I
get into my remarks,
thank the co-chairs of this
event, Mr. Feld and Mr. Osgood,
for the invitation and
for the hard work that you
and all the committee have done
to make this event possible.
Wonderful turnout obviously.
You couldn't get any more
people in here if you wanted to,
so it's a great turnout.
I think, as has already
been said, it does in fact,
as you look around the
room from this podium,
now I get a chance to
see what everybody's
been talking about how
beautiful the room really looks
and how this room really
does speak to the fact that--
this room, quite frankly,
represents a microcosm
of what the world really is.
And these are the
kinds of gatherings,
it seems to me,
that we ought to be
a part of when we talk
about celebrating the life
and legacy of one Dr.
Martin Luther King, Jr.
So much has been
said this morning.
I quite frankly have
said two or three times
to people sitting around me,
I don't know why I'm here.
I mean everything that needed to
be said, has already been said.
It has been said.
It has been sung.
It has been-- you know.
I don't know what else y'all
expected me to come with this
morning.
I told Brother Osgood, if you
ever set me up like this again,
put me up at the
end of a program
when everything has been said,
behind two presidents, two
or three choirs, Eric--
[LAUGHTER]
--and then 45 minutes
behind schedule.
And I'm supposed to
hit a grand slam.
Right.
I've been set up.
It's a setup.
I've been bamboozled,
hoodwinked, run amok,
and led astray.
I am mindful.
I am mindful of the time.
We are running a little
bit behind schedule,
so let me offer some
abbreviated remarks
if I might, but
remarks, I hope, that
would nonetheless cause us to
think as we go along our way.
You'll be happy to know,
as a member of the debate
team at Indiana University,
that my debate coach taught
me a couple of very important
lessons about public speaking.
The first she
called the four S's.
The four S's.
Always remember, Tavis, had to
stand up, speak up, shut up,
and sit your behind down.
Stand up, speak up,
shut up, and sit down.
And she said, secondly, that
a few minutes-- just a few
minutes-- is long enough for a
good presentation and too long
for a bad one.
A few minutes is long enough
for a good presentation
and too long for a bad one.
Now if you're black-- and I see
that some of y'all up in here
this morning are--
that's a black thing
right there, ain't it?
Why black folk always got
to be up in something?
Who started that?
Up in MIT.
Up in the barber shop.
Up in the beauty salon.
Up in folk business.
We always up in.
I don't where that started.
I'm glad you up in
here this morning.
But the point, the point
that I want to make
is that if you're black and
you've been in a church house
before on a Sunday morning, you
know what I'm talking about.
That a few minutes is long
enough for a good presentation
and too long for a bad one.
Last Sunday, at my own
church in Los Angeles,
the reverend was doing good
at about the 22-minute mark.
And then he stretched
it a little longer
than he should have.
And by the time he got
around to opening up
the doors of the church,
wasn't nobody up in there
because he didn't know how
to stand up, speak up, shut
up, and sit down.
I hope, though, in the time that
I have left here to be good,
to be quick, and to be gone,
so that y'all can get on with
the rest of your day.
It seems to me, though,
right quick here,
when you talk about Dr. King in
terms of celebrating his life
and his legacy, the real
essence of King's life,
as far as I'm concerned,
is challenging
each and every one of us.
I believe I can put it this way,
to reexamine our assumptions.
That's my thesis, and
I'm sticking with it.
That King's life and legacy
and his work, at the very core,
at its very essence,
was about challenging
each and every one of us to
examine, to indeed reexamine,
our assumptions.
To reexamine our assumptions.
And everything that King did,
everything that he worked for,
everything that he labored
for, every word that he wrote,
every bit of prose
that he uttered
was all dedicated
to the proposition,
it seems to me, to challenge
each and every one of us,
no matter our station in life,
to reexamine the assumptions,
assumptions about this country,
assumptions about its people,
indeed assumptions
about ourselves.
The life and legacy of King
is about challenging us,
it seems to me, to
reexamine the assumptions.
Now, I've got to lay
this out as my foundation
because if you can't
get with that, then
you can't get with
the rest of what I
want to offer you this morning.
I hope that we can all agree
at least that King's life is
about challenging us to
reexamine our assumptions,
to reexamine those things
that we believe to be true.
There is one thing this morning,
it seems to me, that all of us
have to agree upon,
I hope, beyond that.
And that is that this moment,
today, is a defining moment
in the life of this country.
This is a defining moment.
There have been very few who
have bounded up on this podium
this morning, have stood
behind this lectern,
and have not made
some reference--
either directly or in
some oblique manner--
some reference to
September 11 of last year.
For those who are on the
lecture circuit, those who are--
not just on the lecture circuit,
for any of us, all of us--
it is impossible these
days to have conversation
without having
September 11 come up
at some point as a reference.
Now I'm bothered
by those of us who
look at everything through
the prism of September 11.
I mean, there's a
line here that we
need to be careful
about not crossing.
We cannot look at everything.
Every decision we make cannot be
through the prism of September
11.
You do understand that there
was life before September 11.
And even though I'm getting
less and less confident
of this, Mr. Bush, after we
hunt him down and smoke him out,
after we find him dead or alive,
once we know for certain where
Mr. Bin Laden is and we
get al-Qaeda under control,
life we will go on.
That's the good news.
There was life
before September 11,
and there will be life after
we get this terrorism situation
under some better control.
And so it behooves each of
us not to look at everything,
and not to make every decision,
and not to alter our lives
in every possible way merely
through the prism of September
11.
But having said that, who
in this room could deny?
Who can deny that this is, for
America, a defining moment?
This King celebration
in the year 2002
as Mr. President said a
moment ago is like none other.
Things have changed.
Things are different.
Our lives have been
altered in ways,
I think, quite frankly
forever, but ways
that we don't even yet know
how dramatically our lives have
been altered.
We don't even know all of that.
The whole has not been told
yet of how dramatically
our lives have been altered.
But we all must
agree, it seems to me,
that this is a defining
moment in America.
You still with me?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
SMILEY: All right.
So here's the question for me.
Since everybody's
asking questions,
let me ask a question.
And particularly since I'm
talking to an audience at MIT--
you're much brighter than I am.
I can't tell you nothing anyway,
so let me ask you a few things.
I can do that.
I'm good at asking questions.
I do that for a living
every single day.
But far be it for me to try
to tell you all anything.
It seems to me that if
this is a defining moment,
then the question
is begged today
as to how we take this defining
moment and redefine America.
I lost somebody.
I didn't come all the
way from LA to Cambridge
to just talk about this
being a defining moment,
to simply and merely
celebrate the life
and legacy of Dr. King.
I could have done
that in Los Angeles.
I came here because you
are uniquely positioned
as the best and the brightest
that this country has to offer.
Those who will move from
this place to become leaders
in all kinds of institutions,
in corporate America,
in government, and beyond,
you are uniquely and best
positioned to not just
raise the question of how
we take this defining moment and
redefine America, but, indeed,
to go about the business
of answering that question.
Let me submit something to you.
It would be a travesty,
for me, for this country
to have endured what
we endured on the day
that those diabolical attacks
were levied against the World
Trade Center and the Pentagon.
It would be beyond horrific.
It is, quite
frankly, intolerable.
It is unbelievable.
It is unacceptable,
untenable, quite frankly,
to imagine that after what
we endured on September 11
with planes taking off
from Logan Airport,
that those of you
in this edifice
would allow that day
to come and to go,
to understand that it is
a defining moment for us,
and to not do anything about
taking this defining moment
and redefining America.
Shame on us if we conclude and
agree that this is a defining
moment for our country
and that those of us
who are the gifted,
those of us who have
been blessed beyond measure--
the Bible puts it this
way, to whom much is given,
much is required.
To whom much is given,
much is expected.
If not you, then who?
Somebody has to ask
the tough questions.
Somebody has got
to raise the issue
of how we take this defining
moment and redefine America.
I want to submit
that to you today
as perhaps one of the
most propitious questions
that we ought to
be asking ourselves
at this juncture in
this country's history.
How do we take this defining
moment and redefine America?
Now, one would think that
that has already happened.
Indeed, as I've listened
to folk behind this podium
this morning, there
is some evidence.
The president spoke,
President Vest
spoke, rather wonderfully
to this notion,
as did others who stood up
behind this podium moments
earlier.
Made the argument,
I think, quite well
that there is some evidence that
some progress has been made.
There is some
evidence that suggests
that since September 11, maybe
we've become more humane.
Maybe we've become a
little less nativist.
Maybe we've become
better neighbors.
Maybe there is a little
less racial tension.
I don't know.
I'm not a scientist, and I've
not done a study on this.
All I know is that James
Baldwin put it this way.
Race is not a personal reality.
Race is not a human reality.
Race is a political reality.
And for those folks who
are still black up in here,
up in here, you understand
that Baldwin was right then,
and he's right now that race
is still a political reality
period.
Now, it seems to
me that if we're
going to raise this question
of this defining moment
and how we redefine
America, then there's
a role for each of us to play
in the process of answering
that unique question.
And while there's evidence,
as I said a moment ago--
or intimated at least--
while there's
evidence that suggests
that we have made some
progress, I believe,
I believe that there's
a great deal more to do.
And for those who are
excited about the good that
has come out of September
11, for those who believe
this country is on a new path,
for those who believe that this
is a new day, for those who
believe we've already gotten
the point that America has
already been made exponentially
better by September 11,
from my perspective--
my humble perspective-- let me
disabuse you of that notion.
I do not believe that
enough has been done.
I don't believe, quite
frankly, that we get it yet.
I do not believe that we get it.
We still do not understand what
September 11 was all about.
We don't get it.
Every defining
moment-- I think it's
important to note that every
defining moment does not
necessarily lead to a
redefinition of anything.
I know this is MIT, and I
know y'all believe in cause
and effect.
And we are told for every
cause, there is an effect.
And I guess, you know, I
guess on some level that
must be true.
But it seems to me that we
have a cause for September 11,
but I'm just not sure yet of
what the effect of September 11
is yet or what it is
going to be long term.
I am convinced of this,
that every defining
moment in this country's
history does not necessarily
redefine anything.
Just because you have
a defining moment
doesn't mean there's going
to be a redefinition.
Can I convinced you
of this right quick?
The Civil War was a
defining moment for America.
On the radio show yesterday,
we had Morgan Freeman
on the show, who
many of you recall
was in that wonderful movie,
Glory, about the Massachusetts
54th Colored Regiment.
Denzel Washington, of
course, won an Academy Award
for his wonderful
portrayal in that movie.
But we had Morgan
on yesterday talking
about this regiment in
the context of February
and Black History Month, which
we now celebrate, of course.
And it occurred to me in
our conversation yesterday--
and I've written
about this of late--
that while the Civil War
was a defining moment,
what did it do to
redefine America?
Specifically for black folk?
This blows me away every
time I think about this.
Understand that
in the Civil War--
it is moving every
time I consider this.
Here we are in the Civil
War with black folk
who were, at best, indentured
servants, at worst,
out and out slaves.
At best, indentured servants.
At worst, slaves.
And yet these
Negroes volunteered
to serve, and to fight, and
to die for their country.
I don't think you
feel me on this yet.
Black folk who were
slaves fighting,
mind you, over the
institution of slavery,
volunteered to
serve, and to fight,
and to die for their country.
That was a defining moment.
But what did it do to redefine
America for black folk?
Nothing.
Fast forward.
World War II, a defining
moment in this country.
Negro soldiers,
colored soldiers,
went to war to fight and to
die to serve their country.
A defining moment,
but what did it
do for black folk in America?
Nothing.
Do you realize that these
were colored soldiers,
these were Negro soldiers,
on the train on the way home.
Understand this.
On the train after fighting
on the way back home,
Negro soldiers,
colored soldiers,
had to sit on the train
behind Nazi war criminals.
Sitting on the train
A defining moment.
But what did it do to redefine
America for black folk?
Nothing.
The Vietnam War,
a defining moment.
What did it do to redefine
America for black folk?
Nothing.
Muhammad Ali.
You saw the movie.
Muhammad Ali had this down.
He understood it.
And that's why we revere and
respect Ali so much today.
Of the war in
Vietnam, Muhammad Ali
put it down as only
he could say it.
"You keep asking me,
no matter how long,
about the war in Vietnam.
I sing this song.
I ain't got no quarrel
with the Viet Cong."
Ali understood that.
He understood that the Vietnam
War was a defining moment.
But what was it going
to do to redefine
America for black folk?
Fast forward now to
America's new war.
Here we are in 2002
in America's new war.
And the question, that
urgent question, persists.
What will happen in
this defining moment
to redefine America
for black folk?
Now, let me take this
concept a little further.
The reason why I asked the
question about redefining
America for black folk
is because I believe
in the context of
Dr. King celebration,
and the context of the
struggle, in the context
of African American
History Month,
you've got to start at
that particular place.
You got to start with us.
But I further believe that when
you make black America better,
you make all of America better.
You make black America better,
So I want to be clear
about why I'm starting
with that thesis at least.
You make our
community better, you
make the country a better place.
But what is this
defining moment going
to do to redefine
America for black folk
and for all people of color?
I hope I've just convinced
you that every defining
moment doesn't
necessarily redefine,
which means that somebody
has got to be prepared
to do something, to take
advantage of a defining moment,
and use it to redefine.
How does one do that?
I believe that one
does that by accepting
the challenge that King gave us
to reexamine our assumptions.
We have to reexamine
our assumptions
about a variety of things.
The president mentioned
in my introduction
that there are a
number of media outlets
that we are now employed by.
You know, BET was great,
and it was wonderful run,
but thank God that life goes on.
And now there's ABC,
and there's CNN.
There's NPR and all the
other wonderful things
that we get a chance
to do on a daily basis
vis-a-vis the media.
A quick story.
Months ago, I signed
this contract with CNN
and started doing
commentary for them
during the day side
and prime time for ABC
on Thursday evenings.
And I signed the contract,
and I appeared on CNN
for a couple of weeks.
And then, bam, September 11
came, and all of a sudden,
I kind of disappeared.
So black folks all across
the country, indeed others,
but certainly black folk were
writing CNN, and e-mailing me,
and calling me, and faxing
me, and asking me, Travis--
[LAUGHTER]
That's a joke for those
who really know my name.
They were saying to me,
Travis, we saw you on CNN
a couple of weeks ago.
And now that the war has hit,
we want your perspective.
Where you at?
And as my English
teacher would tell,
you know, behind
that preposition--
but they'd ask me, where you at?
We haven't seen you lately.
And I had to go on
the radio one day,
after weeks of getting all this
mail and all these inquiries,
because I needed to
address this issue.
I didn't want folk to think
that I'd been hired by CNN
and fired that
quickly, you know?
So I had to explain this.
So I went on the radio said to
people, let me just tell you
where I've been at and why you
haven't seen me on CNN or ABC
talking about the war, talking
about the attack of September
11.
This is just a few weeks
removed from the 11th.
I said to them very
quickly and essentially
that I was watching
Politically Incorrect one night
with my friend Bill Maher.
Bill's a dear friend of mine.
I love the show.
But I'm watching
Bill's show one night,
and I see Bill put
his foot in his mouth.
And some of y'all have followed
this controversy with Bill
Maher on Politically Incorrect.
And there is still
a very likelihood
that he will lose his
show, that the show
will be canceled at
the end of the season,
because Bill said the wrong
thing at the wrong time.
Some of you recall that
Bill Maher suggested
in a politically incorrect
format, which that's
what his show is, so I don't
know why he got in trouble,
but I digress.
Bill said in the show that
they had a lot of courage.
It took a lot of courage
for these terrorist
to train, and to
do what they did,
and to dedicate themselves.
It was wicked courage,
but courage to come
do what they did and to
plan it the way they did.
And Bill suggested that
we are a bunch of cowards,
that we were over here
lobbing cruise missiles.
We don't have the courage
of our convictions
to do what they did.
And I understood his analogy.
But the Bible puts it this
way, all things are lawful,
but all things
are not expedient.
All right.
Some of y'all didn't get that.
Let me come at that another way.
How about how
about Kenny Rogers?
You got to know when to hold
'em and know when to fold 'em.
All right.
Now I got you.
Know when to walk away,
and know when to run.
You know, Malcolm X
had his relationship
with Elijah Muhammad
start to deteriorate.
When?
When after the assassination
of JFK, Malcolm X said,
the chickens have
come home to roost.
Wrong thing at the wrong time.
So Bill Maher found
himself in trouble
for saying the wrong
thing at the wrong time.
I saw Bill get in
trouble with that.
I said, OK.
I'm just making notes.
I'm paying attention.
I'm listening to
the radio one day,
and I hear Rush Limbaugh
on the radio one day
go into overdrive blaming the
September 11 attack on William
Jefferson Clinton.
Go figure.
But Limbaugh finds a way to
blame the attack on September
11 on the failed policies of
the Clinton administration.
That's why I love my
friends on the right.
They will always find a way to
blame Clinton for something.
And so Rush got in
trouble for really
jumping out too
headstrong politically
blaming this on Clinton.
Just inappropriate.
Limbaugh got slapped
down, and got in trouble,
and was being challenged in
the media for what he had said.
And then I looked up one
day and saw my friend
the right Reverend Dr. Jerry
Falwell put both of his feet,
hands, everything
else in his mouth
when Falwell suggested that
the attacks could be blamed
on the civil libertarians, on
the feminists, on the pagans,
on black folk, on the ACLU.
Some of y'all saw this comment.
You know I'm not making this up.
Did anybody see this?
Makes sure-- OK.
I want to make sure I'm not
talking to myself up here.
I'm not making this up.
This is a true story.
So Jerry Falwell got in
trouble for blaming it
on basically everybody
except the Christian right.
I said to the audience, after
recounting these stories,
that by my count, that's one,
two, three white boys who all
got in trouble for
running they mouth,
saying the wrong thing
at the wrong time.
I know if I take my fresh
black behind up on CNN and ABC
and put it down the way I
know I want to put it down,
I would be fired
with the quickness--
and you would never ever hear
the name Travis Smiley again.
And so it wasn't the time.
The point is that the
time just wasn't right
for me to say what I
thought needed to be said.
The time wasn't
necessarily right to ask
these tough questions.
But oh, brothers and sisters,
ladies and gentlemen,
there is a time a coming.
And maybe that time is now.
And maybe today is the moment
that those of us who are
dedicated to the principle of
making America better after
September 11, of making this
country live up to her true
ideals, of making these
documents-- the Constitution,
and the Declaration of
Independence in this great city
of Boston--
making our history real,
making these documents living
and breathing documents.
For those who are dedicated
to the proposition
that America can be
made better, there
is no better time than now for
us to reexamine our assumptions
and to take this defining
moment and redefine America.
We got to ask some tough
questions to do that.
Can I offer a few of them
to you as we leave here?
I believe we got to start asking
the question of what patriotism
really is.
Let me get myself up
some trouble right quick.
We got the check already?
All right.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, some places, you got
to ask, do you have to check,
Mr. Osgood.
Some places, you've got to
ask, have we cashed the check.
I know at MIT I ain't got
to worry about that problem.
All right.
I believe we have to
start by asking ourselves
what patriotism really
is and what it means.
Can I just be real with
you for just a second?
Can I keep it real
for just a minute?
I've noticed a distinction here.
There are two things going on.
Some of us are caught
up in the patriotism,
and I ain't mad at you.
Some of us, though, have gotten
caught up in nationalism.
There is a distinction.
Patriotism is one thing.
Patriotism demands that you
make your country better
by asking the tough questions.
Patriotism demands debate.
Patriotism sometimes
demands dissent.
Nationalism is fanaticism.
I'm an American.
I'm going to wave a flag.
I'm down with whatever
Mr. Bush says.
Whatever Congress
says, I'm down with it.
And nobody's prepared
to stand in the gap
and to raise the tough questions
that need to be raised.
And that is not an indictment.
I mean to cast no aspersion
necessarily on the way
that Mr. Bush has stewarded
this country since September 11.
I think, on balance,
he's done a fine job.
But I believe that somewhere
in this debate about patriotism
were King here with
us today, he would
be demanding that we make the
distinction between patriotism
and nationalism.
He would demand that we raise
the tough questions about what
it really means
to be an American.
He would demand that we raise
some tough questions about how
we can become a better
neighbor in the world.
It's not enough to stand
at this podium today
and to call off the names of
all these wonderful countries
that we have Nobel
laureates from
and that we have students from.
MIT is a great institution.
But the truth of the
matter is that, in part, we
found ourselves in this mess on
September 11 because of the way
we treat folk around the world.
We don't want to deal with.
We don't want to deal with that.
[APPLAUSE]
You've got to ask
some tough questions.
The chickens have
come home to roost.
You can't prop up dictators
like Mobutu Sese Seko in parts
of Africa, befriending
anybody who would befriend you
during the Cold
War, and not think
that will come back to
haunt you at some point.
You can't prop up dictators
like Marcos in the Philippines
and think that won't come home
to haunt you at some time.
And the list goes on
and on and on and on
of, quite frankly,
transgressions
that we have made,
mistakes that we have made.
And I hope, at some point,
that somebody has the courage,
that somebody has the
fortitude, that somebody
has the good sense to raise
the kinds of questions
about the very
notion of patriotism
and how we behave or
misbehave in the world
as Americans trying
to big stick people.
Somebody has got to
raise these questions.
And if King were here today--
you're right-- he wouldn't let
you get away with calling him
just a dreamer.
He would challenge us to ask
the tough questions about what
it means to be an American, how
we can become better Americans,
and what patriotism
really means.
King would demand,
were he had today,
that we ask some questions
about foreign policy.
Have you noticed that when
Bush took office, Bush,
Rumsfeld, Cheney, and Rice were
all lined up as unilateralists.
It was very clear.
It's our way or the highway.
It was hawkish.
It was John Wayne.
It was to hell with
the Kosovo treaty.
We ain't signing it.
We going to get out of it.
We're not going to South
Africa to no racism conference.
No, we ain't going.
Our way or the highway, that
was the unilateral approach
when they came into office.
Oh my, how things have changed.
Colin Powell was the only
one standing over here
with a multilateral
approach, saying that we
have got to engage the world.
We've got to be
better neighbors.
We got to rethink how we
do our policy, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera.
They didn't want to hear that.
But now, I have noted at least
of late the administration now
speaking more with one voice.
And maybe now, they're
starting to get the fact
that we have to have a
multilateral, a we, not
an us versus them approach,
to how we engage the world.
But why did it have to come
at the expense of those 3,000
lives at the World Trade
Center and the Pentagon
and in those planes?
We ought to have
better sense then
to understand that we've
got to have a better way
to engage our neighbors and
our friends around the globe.
We've got to raise some tough
questions about foreign policy.
Everybody gets caught up in
this euphoria about Dr. King,
and nobody recalls that King
had dropped precipitously
in opinion polls at
the time of his death.
Go back and check your facts.
King was not at the top
of the popularity polls
when he died because
of his opposition
to the war in Vietnam.
As I recall-- don't
quote me on this--
I don't even think
King made the top five.
He may have barely made
the top 10 in the Time poll
at the time of his death based
upon popularity and likability.
That q-rating that he had
had dropped dramatically.
King understood that.
He wasn't bothered by it.
He wasn't bothered by
because King understood
that the ultimate
measure of a man
is not where he stands in times
of comfort and convenience,
but where he stands in times
of controversy and challenge.
Somebody's got to ask the tough
questions about foreign policy.
It's not just a celebration
of the life and legacy of Dr.
King, but understanding
that we have
to reexamine the assumptions.
This issue of civil liberties
that are, quite frankly, out
of control.
I don't feel safer
today with regard
to the issue of racial
profiling than I
did a few days ago just
because somebody else is now
the target.
No, no, no, no, no.
I know too many brothers in my
neighborhood in South Central
who look like some
Arabs that we think
are responsible
for what happened
who we want to go after.
Are you feeling me on this?
I know some folk of Arab
descent who look just like some
of y'all up in this room today.
The shade of their skin--
are you feeling me on this?
The shade of their skin is very
similar and very akin to yours.
The problem is we have
an administration now
that's doing an overreach
on civil liberties.
I think we all
agree that there's
got to be a balance
between civil liberties
and doing away and
ending terrorism.
But it's got to be done in
a culturally competent way.
It's got to be done in a
socially responsible way.
And I don't know that
we are achieving that.
If King were here
today, he'd be asking
us to reexamine our
assumptions about how we're
going to go after
terrorists, about how
we're going to condone this
racial profiling that's
going on now.
Once they get these laws,
once they get these rules
on the books, as they're
getting every day, a few years
from now, who do you
think these rules
are going to be used against?
You, driving while black,
walking while black,
breathing while black,
living while black,
just being black and brown.
We got to reexamine
our assumptions
about what it means to have this
debate about racial profiling.
Got to reexamine our
assumptions about this.
Somebody's got to ask some
tough questions about the media.
I'm just giving you some food
for thought here this morning.
Did you notice, during
all the coverage, here
you have a city like
New York, arguably one
of greatest cities in the
world, the most multicultural,
multiracial, and multi-ethnic
city in the world.
And yet, how many
people of color
did you see reporting
the news to you
every night out of New York?
Some of y'all didn't
even peep that out.
We're talking about coming
together as a nation.
Do you see the irony here?
Do you see, quite frankly,
the hypocrisy here?
We are talking together about
coming together as a nation,
and we shall overcome,
and God bless
America, and America
the Beautiful,
and yada, yada,
yada, yada, yada.
And yet, I'm watching
the news every night.
I don't see nobody looking
like me reporting the news.
I don't see folk like
me, quite frankly,
routinely who are
victims of this tragedy.
I didn't see no cops
who looked like me.
Wasn't no firefighters
who look like
me because there ain't no black
firefighters in the New York
Fire Department
comparatively speaking.
My point is simply this--
that while we talk
about coming together
and the good that's come
out of this tragedy,
there are some assumptions that
still need to be reexamined.
And King would not let us
off the hook so easily.
He wouldn't let us
off the hook talking
about his life and his legacy
without understanding what
his life and legacy was
about, getting us to reexamine
the assumptions and to
challenge the prevailing wisdom
to challenge the status quo.
Nobody wants to have these
conversations right now,
but these are the real issues.
This is what really
has to happen
if America is going to be made
better out of this tragedy.
Somebody has got to
ask some questions
about religious intolerance,
racial intolerance.
You realize that hate is alive
and well in this country.
They're not walking up and
down the street with hoods
and sheets like they
used to, but hate
is spreading in this country.
And do you know where
hate is spreading fastest?
On the internet.
There are more sites popping
up every month dedicated
to the notion of spreading
hate than any other genre
on the net, any other
genre on the web.
That's one reason, Mr.
President, one of the reasons
why we're doing this
technology summit
and partnering with
Bill Gates and traveling
around the country.
Gates and I were
together in LA last week,
going to three other
cities this year
with a whole tour called
Blacks and Technology.
Free.
Open to the public.
Trying to get black folks to
understand, to appreciate,
to embrace this thing
called technology.
Because I am
determined to not allow
this technological revolution
to pass people of color by
and we not get a little
something something out
of it, number one.
But number two, to
allow this technology,
as the president said, to
be turned in a wicked way
and used against us.
We've got to use it for
our good, for our benefit,
and not allow other folks
to use it for our detriment.
But hate is spreading
fastest on the internet.
Nobody's talking about
technology and how we are
being left out of that process.
We talk about the technology
we have to go hunt people down
and smoke them out.
We're talking about technology
in terms of how we zoom in.
And we're taking credit
for how we use technology
to wipe out this building
and wipe out this truck.
I mean, I'm fascinated
sometimes by how much we've
done in our Defense Department.
We can target a truck going
down the road 10,000 miles away
and take out a truck on a
road with somebody in it
who we want.
And yet, we can't
get our schools
wired in the inner city.
Hello.
Can't wire schools
in the inner city.
But we can't have
that conversation.
See we up here in the clouds
with the life and the legacy.
And that ain't where King was.
King was down here getting us
to reexamine the assumptions.
Finally, there's a litany
of domestic policy issues
that King would be
demanding that we talk about
at the appropriate time.
If we really are talking
about making America better,
it can't just be MIT.
It can't just be MIT
dedicated to the notion
of affirmative action.
We have to have a country
and a government that
understands that
affirmative action is
a corrective policy that works.
Everybody has to
understand that.
Got to understand that.
[APPLAUSE]
That's what King would
be talking about.
We've got to do something
about predatory lending,
about why we go
after people of color
and the indigenous community
and predatory lending ways.
One, you can't get no money.
And if you get it,
they charge you
more to get it because
of what you look like
and where you live.
Insurance redlining.
I could do an end
run on you here.
A long litany of things that
we are not talking about,
that we are not debating,
because we have been stifled
by this war on terrorism.
Immigration policy.
Education.
A long list of things
that we have to address.
And if King were here
today, he would not
be leading us off the hook with
the mere notion of celebrating
his life and his legacy
his wonderful work
and his wonderful prose.
He would be demanding
and challenging
us to reexamine the assumptions
that we hold about America,
about how wonderful we think
we are, about how great
we think we are, about
how wonderful a neighbor
we think we are, about how
good a world citizen we think
we are, and about how wonderful
we all feel about the good--
allegedly-- that has
come out of this tragedy.
I believe that some
good has come out of it.
But I believe there's a
great deal more that we
have to challenge America to do
to live up to her true ideals.
King put it this way.
Cowardice asks, is it safe.
Expediency asks, is it politic?
Vanity asks, is it popular?
But conscience
asks, is it right?
And every now and then,
ladies and gentlemen,
we must take positions that are
neither comfortable, nor safe,
nor politic, nor convenient.
But we do it because
our conscience tells us
that it's right.
There's an old gospel
song that I love so much.
Hearing this choir this morning,
my mind went back to it.
It says, I'm pressing
all the upward way.
New heights I'm
gaining every day.
Still praying as
I'm onward bound.
Lord, plant my feet
on higher ground.
It says, my heart has
no desire to stay where
doubts arise and fears dismay.
Though some may dwell
where these abound,
my prayer, my aim,
is higher ground.
What are we doing to attain,
to reach, that higher ground?
Eric mentioned Morehouse.
Benjamin Elijah Mays, who taught
Dr. King everything he knew,
put it like this.
"The tragedy of life does not
lie in not reaching your goal.
The tragedy lies in
having no goal to reach."
It is not a calamity to die
with dreams unfulfilled,
but it is a calamity
not to dream.
It is not a disaster to not be
able to capture your ideals,
but it is a disaster to
have no ideals to capture.
It is not a disgrace to not be
able to reach all of the stars,
but it is a disgrace to
have no stars to reach for.
Not failure.
Not failure, but low aim is sin.
Now, why does that matter?
Because what gets
most of us most
of the time in our effort
to make America better
is not that we fail, but
that our aim is too low.
It's not that the
president fails
in trying to expand
diversity at MIT,
it's that, too often,
our aim is too low.
It's not that we
fail at what we do
to make our communities better,
it's that our aim is too low.
How high are we reaching?
What goals are we setting?
What are we really
attempting to accomplish?
It's not the failure that
gets us, it's our low aim.
And in trying to make MIT and in
trying to make America better,
when we fail at what
we try, too many of us
get knocked down and
don't get back up.
But my grandmother, Big Mama,
said to me all the time,
Tavis, you can't win
it if you ain't in it.
Advocacy is not a
spectator sport.
To make a difference,
honey, you've
got to get off the sideline
and get involved in the game.
To make a difference, you got
to reexamine those assumptions.
To make a difference, you've got
to ask those tough questions.
Life is like a heart monitor.
It goes up and down and up
and down and up and down
and up and down.
And the ups and
down are all good.
Don't let that sucker
flatline on you.
That's what you're
trying to avoid.
But the ups and downs of trying
to make a contribution, the ups
and downs of trying to make a
difference is to be expected.
I told some students the
other day that being black
is like flying on an airplane.
Being an American, quite
frankly-- forget being black--
being an American is
like flat on a plane.
Forgive the reference.
What do I mean?
When you get on that plane,
you've all heard it before.
They tell you, in
the unlikely event--
they don't want to
scare you to death.
They don't want to
mess with your nerves,
so they tell you, in the
unlikely event of a sudden loss
of air pressure,
the oxygen mask will
drop from the compartment
above your head.
What they tell you
to do with that mask?
Take the mask and
put it on yourself
first before you assist the
person seated next to you.
What's your point, Tavis?
You can't help nobody
else in America
unless you first help yourself.
And that's what these
celebrations are all about,
getting us, getting us to
reexamine our own assumptions,
preparing us to ask
the tough questions,
preparing us, then, to
go out and do something
to help make black America
and all of America better.
In the final analysis I
believe-- and it is true--
that he who starts behind
in the great race of life
must forever remain
behind or run faster
than the man in front.
It's time for all of
us to pick up the pace.
[APPLAUSE]
GOMEZ: Thank you, Mr. Smiley,
for your heartfelt words.
And now, it is my pleasure to
introduce Provost Robert A.
Brown.
Provost Brown will recognize
the 2001-2002 Martin Luther King
Jr. Visiting Professors.
BROWN: It's really a
pleasure to introduce
an outstanding group of
colleagues to you this morning.
The MLK Visiting
Professor Program
was established at MIT to
bring into our community
a wonderful group of black
and Hispanic scholars
to enrich our environment.
I think today has been a
wonderful opportunity for them
to share with us really truly
inspirational talks by a couple
of our students and by Tavis.
And I think that if we did
give honorary admissions
to our undergraduate
class, Tavis
would receive one having
already passed the rhetoric
requirement.
[LAUGHTER]
The MLK program sponsors
faculty and scholars
all over the Institute.
We currently have visitors in
the Urban Studies and Planning
Department, Physics,
Material Science
and Engineering, Chemistry,
and the Sloan School.
Several of them were
with us for breakfast.
A couple have had to
leave because, as is
a calling in the profession,
if you have a class,
you must teach.
And actually, today's
the first day of class.
And if there is a bad form--
for some of us.
And if there is a bad
form for a faculty member,
it's to be late to the
first day of class.
Let me begin by introducing
Dr. Edna Ambundo.
Edna is an MLK Visiting Scholar
in the Department of Chemistry.
She received her BS degree
from the University of Nairobi
in Kenya and her PhD from
Wayne State University.
She is participating in research
and teaching in the Chemistry
Department in collaboration
with Professor Steve
Lippert, the department head.
Welcome, Edna.
[APPLAUSE]
Now the next two
colleagues are not with us,
but I want to
mention their names.
Otis Jennings is visiting in
the Sloan School of Management.
He's completed his PhD
in industrial and systems
engineering at Georgia
Tech University where
he was an NSF Graduate Fellow
and a Georgia Tech Presidential
Fellow.
He received his BS degree in
engineering from Princeton,
and he's visiting the
Operations Research Center.
Raul Lejano in the Department
of Urban Studies and Planning
left a few minutes
ago to go teach.
He's visiting in urban
studies and planning.
His PhD is environmental
health science,
and he's currently
on the faculty
of UC Irvine in the Department
of Urban and Regional Planning.
Phillip Thompson with
us from the Department
of Urban Studies and Planning.
Phil is an associate
professor of political science
at Columbia.
Welcome, Phil.
[APPLAUSE]
He earned his PhD
in political science
from the City
University of New York
and a BA in psychology
from Harvard University
and a master's in urban
planning from Hunter College.
Before joining the
faculty of Columbia,
he was deputy general manager of
operations of the New York City
Housing Authority and head of
the mayor's office for housing
coordination in New York
under Mayor David Dinkins.
Sekazi Mtingwa is visiting us.
He's at the Laboratory of
Nuclear Science and Physics
in the Department of Physics.
Professor Mtingwa
is an alumni of MIT.
He holds both a BS in
physics and mathematics
from the Institute.
As well, he has a PhD in
physics from Princeton.
He joined North Carolina
A&T State University
in the Department
of Physics in 1991
and served as chair
of the department
from '91 through '94.
He's also taught at the
University of Illinois
in Chicago, the
University of Rochester,
and Morgan State University.
Finally, let me introduce
Professor Eni Njoko--
[APPLAUSE]
--who's visiting in
the Department of Civil
and Environmental Engineering.
Eni is also an alumnus of MIT.
He received his PhD
and his SM degree here,
both in civil engineering.
He holds a BA degree
in natural sciences
and electrical sciences
from Cambridge University
in England.
He is currently a research
scientist at the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory where he's a
principal investigator
specializing in satellite
imaging for oil moisture
estimation and the technology
of large microwave radiometric
antennas.
He's also taught at Harvey Mudd
University while being at JPL.
Welcome to you all.
[APPLAUSE]
GOMEZ: We will now continue
with some announcements
relevant to the celebration.
I would like to announce
that the Martin Luther King
Committee presents the student
dedication to the Martin Luther
King installation to commemorate
Dr. Martin Luther King.
Again, that's in Lobby 10, so
I invite you all to go see it.
Now I would like to ask Reverend
Amy McCreath to come forward
to give us the benediction to
close this morning's program.
MCCREATH: Would
you please stand?
Let us go forth with
courage equipped
for the work of doing
justice, empowered
with skills and vision to heal,
to reconcile, and to liberate.
Let us go forth in peace to be
the peace we seek, confident
that what unites us is more
powerful and eternal than what
separates us one from another.
Let us go forth together
locking arms and joining hearts,
strengthening one
another for the work
ahead, celebrating what
we accomplished together.
Together.
Let us go forth in joy,
reveling in the good news
that our creator has called us
at this holy time to holy work
and confident that
love will prevail.
May justice roll down our
limbs and through our veins
and pour out from our mouths
and be the fruit of our labors
that righteousness and peace
may abide like a mighty stream.
Amen.
AUDIENCE: Amen.
GOMEZ: I hope you have enjoyed
this morning's program.
It's been a wonderful
event, which
I'm sure will remain in our
thoughts for a long time.
Thank you all for coming.
And I hope to see you next year.
This concludes our 20th
Annual Martin Luther King Jr.
Celebration.
Thank you.